So organizational structure definitely
plays a role in terms of how
successful DevOps transformation can be.
And I think this is where it's important
to understand that as a DevOps
practitioner you are taking a set
of software development and
operational practices as a base.
But maybe what you are really doing
is you're doing some community
organization.
And so, I think it's important
to understand that your role is
one of someone who is promoting change,
and
this is different from
being a change agent.
So often people think of themselves as,
I'm the change agent and
so, sorry change agents.
But [LAUGH] the way that that
role then gets played is you run
around inside the organization
seeking permission for change.
And so
in a very hierarchical organization,
the pattern that that's going to take
is your in an organizational silo.
You see that maybe you can reach
out to the silo right next to you.
But you're only path for
communication is straight up,
maybe up to the point at which there's
two people playing golf, right.
And then all the way
back down to the bottom.
And that takes time, it's frustrating,
and often you go unheard.
I think the real limitation there
is the limitation of language.
So I think, it's maybe more important
inside of an organization that
is heavily siloed or sort of heavily
structured in that way to take actions
that support your goals in ways
that are that are safe but
that can also communicate value.
For instance,
even in the strongest silo, when you can
identify real organizational pinpoints
and take a step toward alleviating them.
And in today's world these can be
done using open source projects.
There are many ways in which they can
be, these problems can be approached
with a light weight experiment
that's sort of low cost.
I think that's when you are having
now a conversation that isn't one
about organizational structure on
its face but it's one about value.
I think that what you're
doing is you're changing your
relationship to
the organization from one
of permission-seeking to
one of value-seeking.
And I think when you make that
fundamental change internally and you
use that language and you take actions
to support it, people will join you.
I have seen a lot of very siloed
structured organizations, but
I have never found the person inside
them that said I do not want to get
to the big bag of money at the end
of my sort of company journey.
Everyone wants to be successful,
everyone wants to be happy.
And often what we're trying to do is
we're trying to figure out the right way
to match the solution that we see
to the desire that they're seeking.
And I think when you can do that it's
both magical, and it's hugely valuable.
And at that point, the organizational
components really disappear because
now we're talking about value.
I don't want to pretend that
organizational structure doesn't exist.
And I don't want to pretend that
there aren't organizations in which
certain kinds of permission
are going to be required.
You have to be very careful about where
you choose in your organization to test
these waters.
People security concerns are valid.
What goes into a build,
how a build gets out in the world,
how software gets created,
people care deeply about these things.
And often the structure that exists
around them is there for a reason.
So, choose carefully and choose wisely.
The goal is not to get
you tilting at windmills.
The goal is to take clear responsible
steps toward relieving the problems
that you see using the tooling that
you're going to learn in this class.